>>> TONIGHT, A CNN EXCLUSIVE.
ELON MUSK'S SPACEX SAYS IT'S
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY TO RUN THE
CRUCIAL SATELLITE SERVICE THAT
UKRAINIAN TROOPS DEPEND ON DAILY
IN THE BATTLEFIELD.
THIS COMES AMIDST REPORTS THAT
MUSK RECENTLY SPOKE TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN ABOUT THE WAR.
THAT IS A REPORT THAT MUSK D
DENIES.
>> Reporter: IN UKRAINE'S FIGHT
TO PUSH OUT RUSSIAN INVADER, ONE
OF THE MOST CRITICAL PIECES OF
TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T FIRE ROCKETS
OR BULLETS.
IT'S SMALL, EASY TO USE
SATELLITE TERMINALS CALL
STARLINK, MADE BY SPACEX, THE
ROCKET AND SATELLITE COMPANY
FOUNDED BY ELON MUSK.
ACCORDING TO SPACEX, THERE ARE
AROUND 20,000 STARLINK TERMINALS
IN UKRAINE, AND THEY'VE BEEN
VITAL FOR SOLDIERS'
COMMUNICATION, FLYING DRONES,
AND ARTILLERY TARGETING.
>> STARLINK IS THE GLUE REALLY
BETWEEN THE FORWARD DEPLOYED
DRONE AND THE ARTILLERY THAT'S
CONDUCTING THE STRIKE AGAINST
RUSSIAN POSITIONS.
>> Reporter: STARLINK ARRIVED IN
UKRAINE AS THE WAR STARTED,
EARNING MUSK GLOBAL PRAISE AND
THANKS.
CNN HAS NOW EXCLUSIVELY OBTAINED
DOCUMENTS SHOWING NOT ONLY IS
SPACEX ONE PART OF A LARGE
INTERNATIONAL EFFORT GETS
STARLINK'S TO UKRAINE ACE FRONT
LINES, BUT NOW THEY'RE WARNING
THE PENTAGON THEY'RE FACING THE
DIFFICULT CHOICE OF REDUCE
ORGANIZE STOPPING THE SERVICE.
>> WHY AT THIS MOMENT STARLINK
IS RAISING THIS ISSUE.
IT'S REALLY BAD TIMING.
>> Reporter: THE COMPANY SAYS IT
HAS SPENT ALMOST $100 MILLION
AND, QUOTE, WE ARE NOT IN A
POSITION TO FURTHER DONATE
TERMINALS TO UKRAINE OR FUND THE
EXISTING TERMINALS FOR AN
INDEFINITE PERIOD OF TIME.
SPACEX HAS NOW REQUESTED THE
PENTAGON PICK UP MUCH OF THE
TAB, $124 MILLION FOR THE REST
OF 2022, A RATE THAT WOULD
TRANSLATE CLOSE TO $400 MILLION
FOR THE NEXT YEAR.
>> SPACEX IS NOT A CHARITY, OF
COURSE, AND THEY'RE LOSING A LOT
OF MONEY RIGHT NOW AS A
BUSINESS.
SO I'M SURE THEY'RE TRYING TO
RECOUP SOME OF THEIRS COSTS.
>> Reporter: SPACEX'S REQUEST
CAME AFTER UKRAINE'S COMMANDING
GENERAL WROTE IN JULY DIRECTLY
TO MUSK.
THE LETTER OBTAINED EXCLUSIVELY
BY CNN.
STARLINK UNITS PROVIDE
EXCEPTIONAL UTILITY, THE GENERAL
WROTE, THEN ASKED MUSK FOR
ALMOST 8,000 MORE TERMINALS.
INSTEAD, SPACEX SAID THEY TOLD
UKRAINE TO SEND THEIR REQUEST TO
THE PENTAGON, ADDING WE HAVE NOW
EXCEEDED OUR ORIGINAL AGREEMENT
WITH UKRAINE.
WITHOUT STARLINK, UKRAINE SAYS
IT CAN'T FIGHT.
LAST WEEK REPORTS EMERGED OF
WIDESPREAD SUDDEN STARLINK
OUTAGES ON THE FRONT LINE AS
TROOPS FOUGHT TO TAKE BACK
TERRITORY.
>> THEY ARE PUZZLED ABOUT WHY
THAT IS GOING ON.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT SPACEX IS
DOING INTENTIONALLY?
IS THAT COMING FROM ELON?
NO ONE IS QUITE SURE.
>> Reporter: THE OUTAGES AND
NEWS OF THE FUNDING REQUEST TO
THE PENTAGON COME AS MUSK'S
SUPPORT OF UKRAINE IS ALSO
QUESTIONED AFTER HE PROPOSED A
PEACE DEAL, SUGGESTING THAT
UKRAINE RELINQUISH CRIMEA TO
RUSSIA AND HOLD U.N.-BACKED
REFERENDA FOR PARTS OF EASTERN
UKRAINE.
HE SAID UKRAINE DOESN'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT PEACE NEGOTIATIONS
WHILE HE SAID RUSSIA WOULD
ACCEPT THOSE TERMS.
IN THE BACKLASH THAT HAS
FOLLOWED, ELON MUSK HAS
REPEATEDLY INSISTED HE IS PRO
UKRAINE, JUST YESTERDAY TWEETING
AT A UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL WHO
THANKED HIM, SAYING YOU'RE MOST
WELCOME.
GLAD TO SUPPORT UKRAINE.
THE DOCUMENTS WE SAW SHOW THAT
SPACEX FULLY DONATED JUST 15% OF
THE STARLINK HARDWARE.
THE TERMINALS, THOSE ARE THE
TERMINALS, WITH THE MAJORITY,
70% OF THE INTERNET SERVICE, THE
REST COME FROM COUNTRIES LIKE
U.S., POLAND, THE UK AND OTHER
ENTITIES.
NOW ERIN, AT THE SAME TIME MUSK
IS SAYING HE IS GLAD TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE, HIS COMPANY IS NOW
SAYING THAT SUPPORT MAY SOON
SLOW DOWN OR END.
SPACEX IGNORED OUR REPEATED
REQUEST FOR COMMENT, AND A
LAWYER FOR MUSK DID NOT RONALD.
>> ALEX MARQUARDT, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.